auf der intensivstation im klinikum
fulda steht nun mein kollege julius blum
zusammen mit dr thomas menzl julius
erzähl uns doch bitte etwas über die
aktuelle situation tatsächlich in den
notaufnahmen auf den intensivstationen
wie betroffen sind sie durch corona
moritz hat vorhin gesagt 5800 freie
intensivbetten 5008 ist die zahl auf die
sich ganz viele menschen verlassen und
ich will die frage direkt weitergeben
klinikchef dr thomas menzl jetzt
intensiv station auf dem computer wenn
sie dass ihr die zahl der fallenden sie
fällten hören was denken sie na ja wir
haben ja hier auch frei intensiv werden
wenn sie schauen gerade der kollege hat
er erzählt was gleich ausgerüstet mit
den ganzen technischen aufbau ist nicht
jetzt kein paar zentren das in unsere
reserven auf dieser intensivstation
das problem ist natürlich nur ein
patient der in einen solchen bett liegt
der beatmet sicherlich selbst sondern
dafür brauchen wir personal und das ist
im moment die knappste ressource in
diesem ganzen kontext wir haben die
plätze wieder sind auch geschottert
worden was den aufbau angeht da haben
wir uns auch mit daran beteiligt und
zusätzlich intensiv kapazitäten
geschaffen aber entscheidend ist dass
wir das personal brauchen und das
personal was wir im einsatz haben ist
eigentlich schon sehr stark gefordert
wir haben aufgrund der hohen inzidenz
zahlen auch hier in fulda die ersten
fälle von mitarbeitern die entweder
kontaktperson waren deshalb in
quarantäne müssen oder sie sich auch
infiziert haben
außerhalb des krankenhauses und das
reißt weitere lücken und diese lücken
sind für uns sehr sehr schmerzlich weil
die teilweise schon an der betten
sperren müssen
denn wir können nur beten betreiben
wären wir dafür das personal engpass ist
die pflege aber auch im ärztlichen
bereich ist das alles sehr sehr knapp
jetzt haben sie hier im haus bis zu 70
betten die technisch da wären was ist
denn gerade die kapazität und was können
sie dann in dir so wahrhaftig versorgen
gut das ist eine frage die ihnen musste
ich ihn wirklich tagesaktuell
beantworten je nachdem was wir an
krankmeldungen reinbekommen im personal
derzeit sind wir in der lage 28
den sieg betten zu betreiben dann haben
wir noch unsere emc plätze wir sind aber
auch gut will ich meine wir haben
derzeit 15 intensivpatienten mit kugeln
in der betreuung und wir haben dann auch
der normalstation nochmal soviele das
ist schon eine ganze menge so viel
hatten wir früher
und dann haben wir natürlich die
schlaganfälle herzinfarkte auch die
autounfälle die polit raum die zu uns
kommen wir sind überregionales
traumazentrum da ist immer was zu tun
wir sind zu 100 prozent ausgelastet und
wir versuchen mit unserem personal das
zu stemmen da kommt ja noch eine andere
komponente hinzu sie wissen es gibt
pflegepersonal untergrenzen also
bestimmte mindestbesetzung sven die wir
einhalten müssen das macht natürlich für
uns noch schwieriger flexibel zu sein
und das ist der knackpunkt im moment bei
der versorgung in der kurve verdienen
kann das beziffern wie viele mitarbeiter
diese ressource findet einen so ein bett
wenn ich jetzt höre 70 betten gibt es
ein technischer ausstattung aber
ungefähr 30 sind aktuell betreibt war
was muss dann also die
handlungsempfehlung an die politik sein
was menschen
naja wenn sie sich überlegen wie viele
menschen sie brauchen um ein platz rund
um die uhr zu betreiben ein einzelner da
braucht manchmal fünf kommen auch hier
vollkräfte so nennen wir das also
fünfeinhalb stellen damit ein bett 24 7
betrieben werden kann
und jetzt kann eine solche
entschuldigung eine solche person kann
dann zwei patienten betreuen oder
zweieinhalb das ist im moment die
vorgabe und dann kann man leicht
hochrechnen wenn man 70 betten hat und
man so die 24 7 betreiben
dann brauchen sie eine entsprechend
große anzahl von menschen zu viel haben
wir nicht was wir versucht haben jetzt
auch im sommer ist
mitarbeiter zu qualifizieren die nicht
ständig auf der intensivstation arbeiten
das ist wichtig weil dann haben eine
gewisse bisher die müssen wir dann
natürlich von woanders abziehen
aber sie können nicht eine beliebige
krankenpflege kraft auch wenn sie gutes
und examiniert ist die bisher nicht auf
intensiv gearbeitet hat hier hinstellen
und sagen mach mal das braucht der
einfügung dass sie mindestens vier
wochen die es brauchte schon mal dieses
komplexe in bayern wirklich gut bedienen
kann
auch das ist ein thema und wenn wir sie
wollen das abziehen dann stehen sie da
bestens aus das heißt angela merkel wird
von den ministerpräsidenten jetzt
zusammen sie wollen die tochter
maßnahmen wie es aussieht verlängern
wenn ich sogar verschärfen
sind sie dafür uneingeschränkt wir haben
mit dem ersten block down es geschafft
als exponentielle wachstum zu brechen
das haben ihre kollegen derart sehr
schön dargestellt
wir sind jetzt in der plateau phase wir
dürfen nicht vergessen bei uns kommt
dann alles viel später an die patienten
heute positiv gemeldet werden die sind
vor zehn zwölf tagen infiziert worden
das ist der normale gang und die kommt
erst in zehn tagen zu uns in die
krankenhäuser und auch die
intensivstation das heißt die welle ist
gestoppt aber die wutwelle die schiebt
sich noch und wir werden den spitzenwert
nach unserer jetzigen einschätzung erst
ja vielleicht in der zweiten
dezemberwoche erleben und bis dahin
brauchen wir eine weitere reduktion ich
bin sehr dafür dass das was im vorfeld
besprochen werden umgesetzt wird weitere
kontaktsperre verlängerung das wäre für
uns sehr hilfreich
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren